well they're all their old not yourself
but in a way they they they are not you
but you inhabit them it's like acting in
a way or maybe it's like puppetry it's
it's doing a voice in fiction a
character after all is only a voice is
only a voice on a page who's sensibility
is put in language and that's what
that's a little artificial because our
sensibility doesn't only express itself
in language we have a lot going on
inside us that isn't language in
addition to all the language that's
going on but when you create a character
in a book he or she is his or her
language and that language has to stand
for a lot more than what he or she says
it has to stand for their sensibility
entirely so you're creating a voice oh
when you start creating that voice you
are you're doing a kind of puppet show
you're doing a you're doing the voices
as as Dickens once said has one of his
characters say about another character
and I think it's in David Copperfield he
or in all of a twist there's one of the
kids in the band that band of robber
kids and Oliver Twist who reads the
police reports he can read and he reads
the police reports 0 for 4 his gang
because he can read and they love to
listen to him do this and one of them
says to another he do the police and
different voices so he acts out he acts
out the comps he he acts out the
defendants and so when this kind of what
you're doing this is kind of the fun of
writing something you doing the voices
and the voices you hope will become you
know more than just voices but
characters
Oh
I don't think they can because because
as soon as you change something from
from life to language you're making
you're changing it you're changing it in
this in a lockable way it is it isn't
the same you know it's it's something
different and when you put it into
language or even if memory didn't
distort which which memory does you're
still changing it you can't help it I
mean with all the commitment to
documentary realism and truth in the
world you still can't help oh you
because you're creating your own voice
on the page I mean it's it's not fiction
but it's still a creation the voice you
know you write a memoir I write a memoir
your voice is a creation on the page my
voice is a creation on the page and it's
as true as I can make it and it
represents me as if I want if I'm going
to be honest as truly as I can represent
myself but it's still a structure you
know something i've i've invented to be
me I've written this this this style
I've written this sensibility this way
of thinking and I'm saying okay for the
peripheral purposes here in the memoir
this is me this voice you're hearing is
me and that's always there's always
artifice there
you